what's the next topic it wasn't an
extension
evian water spring
let's explain you're talking about the
okay yeah let's explain that so
melanie's like so yesterday i get
there's a very ominous
message from melin all right okay when
is mainly messages not ominous
oh yeah okay okay so so i get this very
ominous message from aiden just saying
hey tomorrow can i uh can i try
something on you
at the office what the [ __ ] is going on
here right now
and she's just like yeah i have this
like ultrasound
thing that i want to put on your face or
something like it's for the baby
is that what it is yeah i guess so
mainly do you want to explain what it
was it's like an ultrasound thing right
no it's like ultra
sonic warm vibration you're just putting
you're just putting buzzwords together
yeah
the only time you hear ultrasonic is in
the sonic game
that is literally just a sponsorship
how much does this cost how much does
this cost me liam
that looks like a vibration that it does
look like a vibrator that does
how much does this cost i don't know i
got for free
from who i don't know who's
i didn't even know they had heavy in
water spray before so yeah so
um so for some reason i just agreed to
it and said yes whatever do
do whatever you need to do melin um and
so she puts this gel on my face
yeah and then starts rubbing that
first she sprays the evian the evian
facial spray which i think is just water
that she is
she just sprayed warts every and water
on my face put a gel on it
and just did a [ __ ] ultrasound on my
face and apparently
we are never getting a sponge it's
really just going back and forth that's
all
[Music]
it's literally that's all it's doing how
is that doing anything
maybe you know if i if i real do i
though
if i actually just got what like a
pregnancy
you're like you're like it felt like she
was going to like she was like
[ __ ] doing ultrasound on my face i
want to start a business where
i just put my mouth against your cheek
and just scream and call it a therapy
the vibrations will heal any kind of
impurities yeah so basically before we
started recording this episode
alien was like i'm just going to do half
of ghan's face so that the boys can see
the
the magic and wonder of the before and
after um could not tell the difference
yeah
we're probably never going to get a
sponsorship from evian but uh it looked
the [ __ ]
same like i don't know like you're the
left can you tell the difference in my
face from my usual
the left side of his face was just a
little bit more moist than the other
side
that's all it was like i don't know what
i don't know what this is supposed to do
but does it though or
or are you just late you don't even it's
for gullible people who want to believe
there's a solution for everything
and sometimes you're just ugly that's
like that's like that's how it is like
that happens
i gotta deal with that no amount of
everyone water spray
everything wrong it's gonna [ __ ] fix
my problems you know what i mean like
it's just it's [ __ ]
that's the thing if if this truly fixed
your ugliness like
no one would be ugly because everyone
would just buy these i will now end
world ugliness
that's been real quiet since that
dropped man
[Laughter]
evian's like we're here to save the day
oh my god we're about to put the fashion
industry out of business
everyone is going to be a model after we
bring out
water spray to the scene there's so much
stuff like that where i'm like i'm sure
it works it's like 0.1 but how much is
it like a negligible amount where you're
like is it worth my time
you know how how how good does it have
to be where i have to sit there and rub
my face and spray avion on it you know
what i mean
how good the results have to be you know
there are just some things where it's
like
i i get the intent as to why this was
invented yeah
but it's also like there are so many
other
alternatives that work just as well yeah
probably a lot cheaper
yeah you know i mean like oh man look
like going back to the whole like
[ __ ] amazon things you didn't you
know you need a thing right like that is
a prime example like that is just like
a bunch of people with like way too much
money who are just going on to amazon
buying all these [ __ ]
like things like i remember it's just
sad because i mean it's just like they
just
they feed off the insecurities that
people have like those like
like they have those uh weight loss
bracelets have you seen those
what apparently just a bracelet that has
like magnets in it or something
oh yeah it makes you lose weight and the
the before and after pictures are the
[ __ ] egregious
they'll be like the most obese person
and then apparently because of this one
bracelet which they probably can't even
get on their hand
how exaggerated this is yeah it's like
apparently this magically makes you
extremely hot it doesn't address the
problem with that if you go from like
500 pounds to 200 pounds
where's the skin gone yeah exactly what
actually sucks back in like
[ __ ] off